every time we write anything about
godzilla
versus kong all the commenters ask why
don't they just kiss
[Music]
no why don't they kiss i want them to
kiss
i think there's a shot where they could
have but they just didn't it wasn't the
right moment for them
are they like different heights they'd
be super awkward like would like king
kong understand
like a little apple box i feel like
there's a lot of tension there
i could see it yeah in general i guess
you know they're both fighting it tends
to be the guys are fighting each other
girls are fighting each other you know
it was on the script but then
you know godzilla's and kong's agents
complained about it
and that's that that was the end of it
we never have been kissing but i regret
that
but i do think that in a sense they do i
mean they're animals and animals don't
mean exactly kiss but there are moments
of connection between them
godzilla would be very touchy with his
forehands i feel like godzilla would
feel like i wouldn't be making
things like that julian i feel like no i
feel like kong's a little bit like
i think dylan's like wait a second
it was kind of just kind of in the space
it's like
i think it's because godzilla doesn't
have lips to be honest right
you know like how is he going to do it
you know like maybe it'd be more like a
lick
they show it to mama tambien with gael
and diego and they thought that's too
much maybe not us
man that would be an awkward kiss too
can you imagine
i don't know if you could kiss godzilla
it would like really rip
the like the edge of your lips and then
poor kong has like
really big lips so that like beak would
go in i don't know
i don't know if this could work actually
they're not allowed space for their
feelings you know
i think that if they've just been able
to have a little bit more uh tolerance
to their feelings
they could have hugged it out you want
that kiss to
to mean something and no better build up
than
an acrimonious relationship when they're
fighting and it's an explosion when they
finally do kiss you're like it's
happening
you know they've been fighting and
trying to kill each other and that's
that finally happened so i think that
this is like a two hour
build up and then the sequel it's just
going to be
love making